the ethics committee is one of the scp
foundation's most important and
overlooked divisions the small secretive
group keeps a close eye on the
foundation to ensure that all decisions
made and all actions taken are for the
betterment of humanity and not just in
service of needless sadism and cruelty
the ethics committee consists of a small
group of people in comparison to the
gargantuan that is the foundation as a
whole it's only natural that every so
often something slips under their radar
and when it does it usually results in
complete and utter disaster in the case
of scp-4051
that something is a male humanoid with a
unique ability to open wormholes to
extra-dimensional spaces and in terms of
disaster well let's just say we hope you
have a pretty tight grip on that red scp
expert coffee mug of yours the wormholes
that
scp-4051 opens are essentially spaces
filled with infinite copies of a single
item which scp-4051 can reach in and
pull out assuming they're small enough
that is the foundation's strict
experimentation schedule has provided a
lot of important data on how
scp-4051's anomaly functions controlled
testing showed scp-4051 was able to
manifest small simple objects like a net
sugar pills or drinking water but he's
also claimed or reported to have
manifested many other things like
aluminum baseball bats duct tape and
more at one point
scp-4051 was allowed to use these
abilities to assist with the site but
the ethics committee recently halted
this seems like a simple enough anomaly
but with the foundation we all know it
never is so let's go back let's start at
the very beginning the foundation first
became aware of scp-4051
when youtube video surfaced online of a
vigilante in an american city using
wormholes to fight criminals the videos
got over 2 million views before the
foundation became aware in august 2012
and stepped in taking it down and
investigating what had led to it a
mobile task force was dispatched to
retrieve the individual using the
wormholes and brought
scp-4051 back to site-17 the first
interview with scp-4051 began on a bad
note
scp-4051 was handcuffed behind a pane of
glass when dr arthur roswell began to
speak to him dr roswell introduced
himself and confirmed that scp-4051's
name was rainer miller after being
assured of his safety
scp-4051 calmed down a little and
stopped struggling with the handcuffs at
dr roswell's request
scp-4051 began to explain the details of
his anomalous power he affirmed that he
could make small objects appear out of
thin air and that he tried to use these
abilities to help people at first he'd
intermittently interrupt carjackings and
robberies subduing the criminal but with
a new criminal syndicate moving in the
crime rate skyrocketed requiring raynor
to patrol much more regularly during
these acts of heroism several witnesses
saw raynor's powers though he tried to
keep them quiet his request for the
foundation to intervene with the
criminal situation was acknowledged as
rayner volunteered any and all
information he had stating that he just
wanted to help the foundation roswell
thanked him for his enthusiasm it didn't
take long for the foundation to move to
experimenting with rainer's powers as
the foundation often does at first they
started slow dr roswell and his
colleague dr edwards asked raynor to
manifest a few small items a metal cube
a bottle of bleach and something of his
choice he was able to produce the cube
without any trouble and the object of
his choice wound up being a framed
picture of his mother when he tried to
take the bleach out he seemed upset but
managed to do it with the experiment to
success
scp-4051 was escorted back to his
containment chamber all the way there he
repeatedly asked how long this testing
phase would take before he would be let
go the staff didn't have an answer for
him in the next test raynor was asked by
roswell and edwards to produce a copy of
war and peace and a phone both were
produced but the book was filled with
gibberish and the phone was entirely
hollow the researchers concluded that
the anomaly is based on how well
scp-4051 understands the object being
manifested and mused about requesting
something that didn't exist raynor still
asked all the researchers how his family
was and whether he would have any
friends at the foundation between tests
the questions were once again ignored by
the staff in the third experiment
roswell and edwards asked rayner to
produce objects that didn't exist a
circular square a color and so on but
scp-4051 wanted to know about his family
and when he would be able to go home
before he would try to manifest anything
roswell assured him that once the
foundation had a solid grip on his
ability he would be allowed to go home
questions about his family revealed that
his mother believed he was away visiting
colleges he demanded to speak to his
mother before any other experiments and
roswell affirmed that he'd asked the o5s
for approval when the experiment in
question was finished raynor agreed and
began the experiment trying to produce
the impossible items what came out were
cognito hazards severely damaging the
mental state of anyone trying to
perceive them half the research team
instantly collapsed and security guards
subdued rainer to take him back to a
cell the testing chamber was cleaned and
dr edwards wrote that the value of
scp-4051's anomaly was too great to let
him sit in a box unused he called for a
special pediatric therapist and
authorized further experiments on raynor
but in his own containment cell raynor
was still knocked out after the test had
gone wrong the cameras watched on as he
woke up and began curling up and away
from them toward the other side of the
room then standing up a few minutes
later he had manifested many small
pieces of body armor and glued them to
his body the guards were distracted with
escorting roswell and edwards from the
testing chamber and didn't realize
anything was wrong until rainer
manifested a small bomb and blew his
door open leaving his cell other
security guards immediately turned and
responded trying to subdue scp-4051 with
non-lethal weapons eventually a few were
able to overpower and incapacitate
raynor and move him back to his cell the
day after the containment breach site
17's director thomas graham sent out an
open letter to all staff assigned to
scp-4051
raynor had been moved to a more secure
containment unit but everyone agrees
that it would be better in the long run
if scp-4051 is working for the
foundation rather than against it
especially with regards to amnestics
sourcing y-909 a chemical used in
amnestics was dangerous and expensive
for the foundation but if raynor's
abilities could be harnessed to produce
amnestics easily then he would be all
the more valuable to them as a friend
rather than a foe the ethics committee
also required that scp-4051 do so
voluntarily for the foundation rather
than being forced to produce amnestics
against his will to that dr edwards was
promoted to scp-4051's project director
on the basis that he would try to ensure
raynor would be totally and utterly
loyal to the foundation using whatever
means necessary he already set up a
schedule using punishments and rewards
along with regular checkups from an
on-site therapist the therapy sessions
began on a good note dr yesenia the
therapist assigned to scp-4051
introduced herself politely and raynor
seemed to take a shine to her they
discussed his unique anomaly and the
containment breach incident yesenia was
kind and understood the psychological
toll containment had on people she asked
why he wanted to escape and he explained
he just wanted to see his family he was
close with his mother since his father
had walked down on them when raynor was
just a boy they had been supporting each
other since and he missed her a lot that
said he explained he wasn't opposed to
living at the foundation they could help
him actually understand his powers and
he didn't mind being a part of tests if
he knew he was helping people he just
wanted to see his family again yesenia's
after meeting notes said that the
containment effort should be focused on
assuring rainer that the foundation had
his best interests in mind the next set
of experiments were a little more
abstract dr edwards alone was overseeing
them and the first experiment included
another individual a d-class the plan
was to see if the d-class could also
pull things out of the portals or if
only
scp-4051 was able to interact with his
portals the d-class was scared of rainer
but after some urging by dr edwards he
managed to touch the sides of the
portals and reach in and pull out a
stone raynor was only anomalous in his
ability to manifest the portals so
edward's plan was to cut out the
middleman and to perform research on
scp-4051's brain to see if they could
successfully devise an artificial method
of creating the portals the experiment
after that was to see the bounds and
geographies of the pocket dimensions
that rayner generated a gps tracking
chip was thrown into one of the portals
as cp-4051 made specifically the portal
leading two portraits of his mother the
portal shot then raynor was asked to
recreate it the researchers checked to
see if they could still get a solid
signal from the tracking chip and they
did albeit almost a thousand kilometers
away the results were filed away but
edwards noticed one thing the portrait
of scp-4051's mother was slightly
different it seemed that he was
forgetting what she looked like the next
therapy appointment with dr eusenia
covered how rainer felt about that
experiment he was excited that they were
actually performing research about the
anomaly that he wasn't capable of just
telling them that they were now finding
out something interesting about his
powers eusenia asked if he had any
requests for tests but he doubted that
edwards would listen to anything he said
the doctor seemed to dislike raynor for
some reason he couldn't figure out but
he knew best on what to test and how
meanwhile edwards had come up with
something that could utilize
scp-4051's abilities in a useful way for
the project of synthesizing amnestics
procedure 350 promethean the details of
this clandestine project are murky and
secretive but the goal was to see if
they could use raynor as a live method
of synthesizing y909 through an
experimental surgical procedure several
contingencies were planned if the
wormhole became too dangerous or rainer
tried to resist he'd be automatically
injected with paralytics and sent back
to his cell the project wasn't
immediately approved though the ethics
committee sent one of their most skilled
liaisons jeremiah simerian to conduct
the approval process he interviewed dr
edwards ascertaining that the man was
sane and able to conduct the procedure
that any unethical actions that were
outside of the scope of the proposal
would result in his removal from the
team and disciplinary action moreover he
revealed that he knew that dr roswell
scp-4051's original researcher was
edward's brother and that he had been
permanently injured in the incident when
raynor was asked to manifest impossible
objects edward swore that he wouldn't
take any needless actions to cause
intentional pain and suffering and that
everything he would do would be in
service of the foundation's goals with
that procedure 350 promethean was
approved meanwhile dr roswell's
condition wasn't improving he had been
put into an induced coma by medical
personnel due to his extensive exposure
to the cognito hazards he wasn't
expected to recover anytime soon after
the ethics committee approved the
procedure dr edwards stopped conducting
usual experiments the very next test
involving scp-4051
was the first implementation of
procedure 350 promethean but it failed
raynor broke the restraints on the chair
during the painful procedure and edwards
considered tranquilizing him but decided
against it we needed a wake he said the
next therapy session though raynor
didn't so much as mention the procedure
instead he greeted dr yesnia explaining
that he wasn't doing so well he had
talked back to a guard and they had
taken his desk away as punishment and he
felt like it was his own fault dr
eusenia was worried and offered to see
if she could get the desk back but he
declined the offer saying he'd just try
to be better after the session yesenia
felt annoyed not by raynor but by
edwards he had been saying that the
subject was getting resentful and rude
but raynor still seemed like a sweet
helpful child the next time procedure
350 promethean was enacted it was the
first time edwards actually managed to
successfully complete it
scp-4051 was actually being compliant
with the procedure making the job a lot
easier for the surgical staff the
results and details of it however were
still unclear in the therapy session
after that raynor told dr eusenia that
he had been having terrible terrible
dreams every night nightmares that
stopped him from sleeping he worried
that people would treat him like a freak
not because of his anomaly but because
of what happened with his father dr
euzenia encouraged him to tell her she
already knew but felt it would be good
if he let it out and he shared his
memory of how his father had locked him
in a closet and abused him burning him
with bleach that's why he'd been upset
when asked to take a bottle of bleach in
the first test his nightmares were about
not being able to escape something that
was coming toward him and that his
father could still be out there but
yesenia admitted to him that while she
shouldn't be telling him his father had
been found by the foundation he was
serving a life sentence in an arkansas
prison for murder rainer grew quiet for
a moment before changing the subject
yesenia's observations were optimistic
and she believed his mental health was
improving and that he was now fitting
into his role at the foundation though
she wondered how edward's experiments
with him were going the next
implementation of procedure 350
promethean went poorly edwards wrote in
his diary angrily afterwards that laner
didn't even remember roswell or
recognize his name how he was angry that
he was assigned to the anomaly that had
nearly killed his brother he had an
outburst during the experiment and it
was shut down early but only a week
after another attempt was made while the
procedure was being done rainer asked
about roswell but was cut off the
research team knew that if he was told
what he had done to dr roswell his
mental health would crater and
negatively affect the project in spite
of that the procedure was a success and
edwards took credit for the whole thing
they were getting closer to being able
to completely make use of
scp-4051's anomaly in his next therapy
session raynor recounted how he liked
being out and about in nature and how
the containment cell had become a
suffocating prison yesenia suggested she
might be able to swing a treadmill in
this room to keep him active if she
bothered her superiors but he didn't
want her to get in trouble he seemed
worried and upset he voiced that he
didn't think these experiments were
helping people anymore that he was being
a burden yesenia had an idea she could
ask the director to allow raynor to help
out around the site fixing little things
and helping clean things up it wasn't
much but it would allow him some
activity and boost his morale about
helping people all while making use of
his anomaly raynor was excited he loved
the idea and had been scared about being
stuck in a cell uselessly after this
session yesenia reflected that it seemed
cruel to manipulate scp-4051
into wanting to help the foundation when
he so obviously already wants to help
and just like she said it didn't take
long for the director to authorize a
security clearance for scp-4051
just enough to be outside his cell when
accompanied to help with site
maintenance while rainer was off fixing
things around the site yesenia decided
to do some digging and asked for
information about the experiments
edwards was conducting but didn't have a
high enough clearance meanwhile edwards
had come up with a prototype for a
machine that can mimic scp-4051's
abilities a few weeks after it was
approved site-17 had a minor containment
breach and a few hostile anomalies
overran armed personnel raynor was
present at the time and used his
wormholes to terminate the anomalies
before containment was re-established
even though he saved lives yesenia was
forced to reprimand him for using his
powers without authorization that he was
banned from any maintenance for two
months several months later the machine
to mimic raynor's powers 350 janus isn't
working correctly and keeps producing
the wrong object eusenia keeps
requesting information on edwards
experiments but is denied every time
even when she asks the ethics committee
for a review on the project the machine
worked but only once breaking right
after
scp-4051 story is a strange one it
involved an mtf mission sent into a
dangerous area to contain an object with
raynor sent along with them the full
mission log has yet to be declassified
and maybe we'll cover it in a future
video but for now let's just say
something went wrong during that mission
the foundation discovered something new
and dangerous about
scp-4051's powers and a closer eye fell
upon the project the ethics committee
re-evaluated what had gone on with
scp-4051
and the site director surrendered
information that edward's experiments
hadn't been all in the name of science
that he might have been needlessly cruel
and violent to an innocent anomaly just
because he wanted revenge for the
accidental mutilation of his brother
after taking a closer look the ethics
committee came to the decision that
scp-4051 needed to be rethought large
portions of the document were redacted
and classified and they tried to bury
the project
scp-4051's powers were too dangerous to
allow about the site his permissions
were revoked and he was placed into
permanent containment in a more
specialized cell the researchers of the
foundation need oversight otherwise you
get incidents like scp-4051
where a vengeful doctor subjected an
otherwise innocent being to brutal
surgical experiments and manipulation
under the guise of research it goes to
show that the foundation isn't always
the good guy in fact from the
perspective of the anomalies the
foundation can be pretty damn evil now
go check out
scp-4999 someone to watch over us tail
and scp-999 the tickle monster for more
anomalies of the friendly nature from
scp explained